herr mit hallo mein name ist luca ich
bin heute das spiel stroh face quest das
hat glaube ich schon jeder irgendwie mal
gespielt hallo
ja es ist ja herrlich ich werde mir bald
man noch so schaumstoffmatten für
überholen oder halt so coole wende damit
das nicht so klug als sehen uns mehr von
anfang an mit dem spiel mein ellbogen
attacke gegen killergames eine play game
change or not to be the next level wie
sonst jetzt irgendeinen rat entscheiden
können wir nicht
[Gelächter]
wir mussten einfach nur auf den auf
button drücken wir gehen mal ins nächste
level und müssen uns jetzt entweder für
die blaue oder für die rote pille
entscheiden kann ich nicht ich nehme die
rote pille was ist wenn wir die blaue
pille nehmen auch tot das war klar es
muss wieder irgendwas domes sein was ist
wenn ich einfach mal nichts zurück und
er seine band dann ok ich muss irgendwas
nehmen was ich habe einfach auf sein
auge gedrückt natürlich die in die augen
gesteckt ok muss unbedingt auf die leute
das heißt wir nehmen den schlüssel als
ob der sich einfach gerade mit dem
schlüssel getötet hat ist er bescheuert
dann will jeder hier in die tür ist
verschlossen da nehmen wir doch einfach
einen schlüssel und stecken mit den
blumen können wir hier nicht
ich verstehe das spiel nicht das ist
einfach so drückt gegen wasser und
irgendwie mit glück kommt so weiter sag'
mal habe ich dieses spiel schon mal
gespielt oder habe ich da zu dieser wie
momente irgendwie level fällt alles klar
habe ich das schon mal gespielt ich
google dann immer so auf solchen
webseiten die spiel ab
gibt es also seiten in die richtung dass
es so für coole spiele gibt die man eben
die zocken könnte die nicht so groß
nicht zu klein von so kleinen indie
entwickler damit man ihn noch ein
bisschen pusch gekonnt crafter troll
face quest und dieses spiel habe ich das
ist wieder mal ein internet das ist
einfach nicht lädt ich habe das spiel zu
spiel gucken wenn ich control space
quest amg bekommt nur chaos
danny kommen marke player kommt aber
nicht ich habe es tatsächlich noch nicht
gespielt hätte wie so kontinent so vor
als ob ich das irgendwie schon mal
gespielt hätten ich klicke auf jeden
fall auch restart drücken das ganze hier
nochmal das kann es nicht sein das hat
mir vorhin schon
wir können uns allerdings ändern dass
mit der gasmaske sieht eigentlich schon
mal ganz gut dann machen die nicht so
und ich weiß ganz genau dass wir nicht
so mache das davon vitamins auf twitter
lang
er brennt die sehen aus wie dankbar ich
bin schon wieder tot aber ich muss doch
irgendwie hier irgendwo geht dagegen
wollte jetzt bin ich durch den blitz
gestorben wartet so
was passiert denn wenn er wenn ich ihnen
einfach mal hier verbrennen lassen kann
ich dann dass sie eben eher nicht
einfach und wie geht das level können
wir das ist ja noch nie einfach hier und
da ich kann ja auch nichts anderes
berühren außer die regenwolke oder die
leute hier dann kriege ich mal wieder
auf die leute und wenn die nämlich jetzt
schießen dann bin ich tot wenn ihr das
spiel schon mal irgendwo anders gesehen
bringt ihr euch wahrscheinlich auch luca
du bist ja so einen dummen batzen das
funktioniert natürlich so und so ähnlich
kann auf diese erst drauf klicken und
dann kann ich auch die haben die den
gerade angepinkelt ich gegen einen stier
ich habe die chance mit dem schwanz
wedeln mit der frage was gefällt ich
liebe doch noch
denn was gefehlt roth level feld sorgt
grün arm hoch rot gefährdete dann kann
ich was mit dem ich stehe weil es sonst
nirgendwo eine scheiße sender hat neue
freunde
das ist ein viertel stunde vergangen
haben kaffee getrunken beruhigt habe ich
mich jetzt nicht was macht der da halo
kann ich nicht irgendwie auch in dem
drauf auch wenn ich auch den fahrer
starb draufklicken das irgendwie mal was
[Musik]
das kann doch nicht sein ich fahre zum
ziel
ich hab's geschafft freunde was passiert
wenn diese komischen teile von ich weiß
nicht warum aber irgendwie sind wir im
nächsten level gelandet ich mache das
immer so dass ich dann oft probiere wenn
nicht wichtig mit dem weg nicht weiter
kommen damit das video nicht tausend
jahre lang wird ich habe es dann eben
die probiert und auf einmal liegt er
stehen und dann stand da wo du hast es
geschafft
also da habe ich jetzt nichts geht wir
haben zwei verschiedene drehte einmal
den roten und den grünen und die clips
an und wir müssen dahin das heißt wir
laufen mit dem typen da hin und mach
doch was hier mit den teilen kannst du
damit nicht einfach irgendwie mal
entscheide dich doch für entweder den
roten oder den grünen draht kannst du
nicht irgendwie danach hand nehmen 108
an seiner hand drauf klicken die hand
und dann darüber
hallo die griechen dahingegen wie du mit
anteilen von tro fels 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
[Musik]
level fällt das war klar was ist wenn
ich zehn mal raufgehen hier draufklicken
dann befällt klicks and times und rolf
age 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
da ist ein stein über mir und ich muss
irgendwie okay ich habe eine 50
50-chance alter ist dass der ernst von
dem spiel was ist wenn ich den
telefonisch
[Musik]